he's at this thing in ohio talking about
whirlpool and stuff
and then he says i got a lot of enemies
rich people
don't like what i'm doing so you might
not see me for a while yeah he's like
these rich people they're really mad
yeah there's a lot of people who are mad
yeah the democrats and i'll tell you
what if if if you've got these anti-for
far lefties saying
that they'll they'll do whatever is by
any means necessary they say
yep i i ask my i ask people i know when
they like tell me auntie was not that
bad i'm like what do you think by any
means necessary
means and and plus they were holding up
this sign that says
we don't want to reform anything the
only way
to change it is to burn everything down
and it has a big flag they're carrying
they're around they're walking around
with signs to say revolution nothing
less
yeah i'm like they're telling you what
they want to do
yeah who they are what they believe in
they're violent
now of course the media is starting to
realize you know
yeah hey the american people don't like
riots
this is why you've already lost them
they already don't trust you they
already are pissed at these rioters
these peaceful protesters as you
yourself media has declared them
i think ridiculous this is why i think
what's really happening is the democrats
are absolutely inept yep because if it
really was this like nefarious plot
where they were like
now we're going to cheat then they
wouldn't be playing catch-up with trump
right so i think they genuinely were
like oh we should have mail-in ballots
because then we'll get big voter turnout
and then in california they didn't
like older voters turned out more yeah
younger voters didn't
and now mail-in ballots are all broken
so now they're like
yeah like new york took six weeks and
about 84 000 disqualified 84 000 people
disqualified
yeah it's totally totally broken crazy
so now
now you're ending up with this for the
past several months
the riots have gotten worse people
obviously don't like them
trump was the only one doing anything
about it and still trump is the only one
doing anything about it
the cops are certainly arresting people
the courts are just letting them go
and now we have quite honestly i think
it's one of the funniest stories
i love i love this is great this is from
the daily beast
i'm not scared she faces life in prison
after allegedly buying red protest paint
oh is that all a protest pain she bought
protest paint
protest paint she's right that's all she
did i i realized that in the eyes of the
state i'd become an enemy for exercising
what is supposed to be a protected right
now now i have some questions before we
even read this we're going to tear this
article to shreds mind you
she why why does she have bruises on all
of all up her arm if all she did was by
paint did she slip and hit and and fall
in the paint
hit her arm she must have slipped and
fallen down the stairs and
she really bumped her arms protesting
tim no no no no no she only bought red
paint
yeah that's right that's all it says so
she's at you know home depot
she says one red paint please they hand
it to her and then she goes whoop slips
falls down and the paint can
repeatedly strikes her arm as it bounces
and now she's injured that's
and then they came in and arrested her
do i feel bad for her how dare they how
dare they yes look at this
madalina mcneil is accused of buying red
paint before a protest
under aggressive new criminal charges it
could mean she spends the rest of her
life in prison
mcneil 28 was among four people charged
tuesday for their alleged actions at
a july salt lake city utah protest over
a district attorney's decision
that the fatal police shooting of young
men was justified protesters allegedly
splashed red paint on the da's office
broke windows and hung signs calling for
justice for the slain man
but instead of merely charging the
protesters with vandalism or even riding
that same d.a used a charging
enhancement to claim they operated as a
gang
under these new charges the
demonstrators face up to life in prison
it's the latest in a pattern of harsh
measures that ratchet up potential
penalties by treating protesters like a
criminal conspiracy
you know what protesters no no no no no
it's a gang congratulations
congratulations that's the way to do it
they are a gang they're dressing the
same they're wearing right gear
they're going out they're literally the
same flags
how much how much you want to bet how
much you want to bet when they charge
the proud boys with gang violence
this this writer had nothing but
negative things to say
about the proud boys and nothing but
positive things to say about their
finally being arrested
i i would bet with you there in new york
city antifa showed up to
uh an event where gavin mcinnes was
speaking and the proud boys were there
when the proud boys left they had antifa
all littered all over about you know
about this area
so finally a scuffle breaks out that the
police wanted to charge both groups but
antifa
i gotta admit they're much smarter when
it comes to law enforcement refused to
cooperate
they got stomped out you know but they
were both basically trying to fight
the antifa guys were taunting him and
heckling him the proud boys run up to
him the guy throws a bottle
a fight breaks out antifa got stomped
brutally
the cops came the proud boys cooperated
and now they're going to prison i think
they're in prison and antifa refused to
cooperate and fled
the police were like we would have
charged them both with gang violence
but they fled so now only the proud boys
get in trouble
i guarantee you they didn't care this is
the daily beast writers and all they
didn't care
they were they were probably like good
charge them they're a criminal gang
okay when you post messages with a name
like they're doing in portland over and
over again
they have a they have a branded name in
portland and i'm not talking about rose
city but you know rose city is the
typical antifa group that everyone talks
about
there's another group that organizes on
on twitter and says everyone show up
here and wear this
yep okay y'all are in a gang dude
definitely and you're in
so did you hear what the uh the mayor of
portland said the other day
he accused antifa of attempted murder
wow
because they blocked the exit to the
police station and tried to burn it down
with people inside
jeez and you know it's funny that night
they did it again
of course and little old ladies came out
amazing you saw the little old ladies
yeah they're my new heroes how insane
man little old ladies came out to defend
the police station put the fire out
and they were they they splashed her in
the face with paint yeah she's got paint
in her eyes
dude and she wouldn't leave she was just
standing there like a boss
but then they went props to you two old
ladies
perhaps then they went to a residential
neighborhood
and one of the locals came out with a
weapon mm-hmm
yeah man you know the reason why they
call themselves anti-fun black lives
matter as most people probably realize
is so that they can play this stupid
game where you're like
hey i would appreciate it if you stopped
throwing paint and you know the faces of
little old ladies they'd say
what are you a fascist are you are you
saying that they don't matter
how dare you you're saying black lives
don't matter are you a fascist because
we're
anti-fascists so i announced on twitter
i'm starting an organization called the
weak and vulnerable elderly grandmothers
that way when a group of weak and
vulnerable elderly grandmothers
are playing a game of you know uh tackle
football down to local park antifa shows
up with some complaints
after the fight breaks out it'll be
antifa attacks weak and vulnerable
elderly grandmothers
and then when they say nuh-uh they're a
bunch of you know ruffians playing
football i'll be like
you hate weak and vulnerable elderly
grandparents
well they identify as as the weak and
vulnerable elderly grandmothers
yep we all identify and then we'll we'll
be flexing we'll get some bodybuilders
oh but i'm a weak grandmother oh don't
you oppose me and the media like morons
will just churn it out yup the weak and
vulnerable other grandmothers were
viciously attacked by antifa
they're like getting good clicks this is
good clicks
so i'll tell you what the issue with
this article is the headline yep
she she faces life in prison after
allegedly buying protest paint
no no no no no the headline should be
she faces life in prison after engaging
in gang violence
and purchasing weapons and materials and
vandalizing a da's office yep that's
your title
but you know what they do with this
people are going to share the title
and they're not going to read the
article when the article pops up on
twitter people
people are going to be like oh no what's
happening and that's it fascist
well how about we go to uh cbs and even
this is funny
utah protesters who splashed red paint
and broke windows
could face up to life in prison because
of gang enhancement
i'm sorry man i'm not going to be crying
anytime soon
look i i i always value freedom over
security i'll tell you what
but these people have been given a free
pass to go around and smash everything
up
and now they're getting comeuppance
there have been riots going on
endlessly mostly in portland for sure
but there there there have been riots in
other areas
let's let's read cbs's take on this
and and and they even straight up say
look at this black lives matter they're
not calling it antifa
well of course they accidentally
misspelt rioter right here
black lives matter rioters in salt lake
city have been accused of splashing
paint on a road
and smashing the windows of the district
attorney's building at a july protest
riot i'm sorry and now the charges they
face carry a maximum sentence of
life in prison prosecutors charged
multiple and this is in
this is utah right yes salt lake city
they're not messing around yeah nah this
is this is not seattle men
prosecutors charged multiple protesters
with the crimes on wednesday
the associated press reported the
charges have more severe consequences
because salt lake city district attorney
sam gill upgraded them
with a gang enhancement which increases
the penalties for offenses committed in
concert with two or more person
or in relation to a criminal street gang
that's exactly what they are
that's what i mean that's exactly what
they are they're a street gang
it is under the guise of being virtuous
i do think
three people it's like it's a hard law
to do to be honest
like i guess but but it's in concert so
so there you go so if three people are
walking down but
think about this way let's say you meet
up with you with your two friends okay
and then you know you see people get
into a fight so the three of you jump in
and get engaged engage in the fight
okay they charge you with a crime
there's three of you acting together
they upgrade the crime to life in prison
you know what i mean this is different
obviously i mean
they all wear riot gear they're all
protected
wearing helmets you know they're wearing
the same clothes they have a uniform
yeah exactly i'm saying
it's the difficult thing with gang with
gang laws are that like
if three people you know go out and do
something dumb is it they're not in a
gang you know what i mean right but
there's got to be a threshold they set
somewhere because how do how to identify
gangs which makes it difficult but this
is what judges are for
true right so this is i've talked to
lawyers about this and they're like
even when laws seem like they're over
the top or not enough
judges have their discretion that's the
point yeah you have the written law and
then you have the interpretation to the
judges so
i'll tell you what man if uh you get a
name and you're organizing on twitter
with your branded name
you tell people to show up and they do
and they're buying weapons and stuff
and then they're destroying things and
you're all wearing the same clothes
that kind of sounds like a gang to me
yeah or a
mafia huh i mean the same thing
i know where gang comes from gangsters
right so let's see they say with the
enhancement
second-degree felony charges which is
you which usually have a sentence of one
to 15 years
can be upgraded to life in prison look
man i don't like the prison system it's
only gonna make these people crazier or
worse
actually i take that back you know why
when
you do you know who the bike lock basher
is i know of it who
was that guy's name his name was eric
eric what he was a teacher of philosophy
i believe at berkeley yeah i remember
finding his mildly ironic yeah
he was an adjunct the bike lock basher
yeah he's a he's a super villain
tell us about he went around with a bike
lock in berkeley and he bashed seven
people over the head
with a bike lock and and these these are
kill shots
yeah there was one dude on his knees
with his hands up okay and he comes out
of the crowd and he just cracks them
over the skull
jeez yeah so these people are
nuts i suppose yeah but this guy
had the strikethrough tattoo on his
chest okay all right which is the antifa
symbol
of the three arrows do you think that
guy
would fare well in a prison for violent
offenders
no what kind of groups function in
prisons
gangs gangs and what kind of gang are
the white people in
white supremacy so what do you think is
going to happen when the scrawny
you know white hippie dude shows up why
i shouldn't call him hippies violent
and he's literally got the tattoo you
know
they're going to be like what's up what
are you going to do about it yeah that
guy would not survive
no no no look i got to be honest my
understanding of prison is based on
movies
and tv shows so it's probably not
completely accurate no i i watched this
um this youtube video about an
ex-convict who was talking about these
these antifa types saying they have no
idea what they're
in for if they go to prison literally
what you're saying that's what he was
saying because he was saying
the these gangs these they they operate
in groups
every single different type of group
exists inside of a inside of a
free space right and it is and it's sad
but it's true i mean
you know that i i you know i think it's
sad but that's
that's what the reality is so these
people they're like anti-fascists
anti-racism they they get put into
prison
where they have tattoos they have no
group
every single person in there is like
you're you're
minced me well you know what man this
guy got got uh he basically got a free
pass
he got let go he tried he basically
tried to kill seven people and they
wouldn't even charge him with this stuff
what there's a guy probation there's a
guy on his knees
with his hands up trying to stop the
fighting and he cracked him over the
head
that's insane yeah it's insane these
people are terrorists
wow yeah targeted a dude on his way
where was this in berkeley in berkeley
yep
a guy got on his knees in between both
crowds putting his hands up and tried
stopping people from fighting
so he cracked him over the skull with a
bike lock we call him the bike lock
basher
so these people man life in prison huh
they'll what what do you think's going
to happen to them if they go to prison
for that long
they're not going to go to prison for
life no no no it's not even about life
it's about prison so if they go to
prison
they're going to get they're going to
become someone's uh how long do you
think they're going to cry for like i
can't say the female dog
what's the slang for that that is
excuse me that is a sexist stereotype it
is offensive
it's offensive hate speech thanks for
clarifying how long how long do you
think these people are gonna cry for
oh man how long do you think she cried
for when she found shawshank redemption
right
yeah where the they bet on who's gonna
cry first yeah yeah yeah i'd put my
money on all of them
yeah no but like how long will they be
crying for oh man because we know
they're gonna cry
you know well they're going to toughen
up eventually over the
things they're going to be dealing with
you know it's kind of crazy i can't
remember what movie it is that i saw but
it was about this dude who goes to
prison
and it was like he was a he was a
teenager
you know i can't remember what the movie
was he goes to prison and he becomes a
white supremacist
because like that's the gang he had to
join okay and it turned him into that
when he got out of prison that was his
whole world now
so it was like it's a yeah something
like that could you imagine these antifa
people running around yelling like bash
the fash
and like throwing paint and screaming
and crying they come out of prison all
like hard as stone and super racist
like just a total inversion of whatever
it is they are now yeah
you give them a few years and their only
survival is to toughen up
and join a gang yeah and all of a sudden
there's you know i'll tell you what no
the good the good news for my guess is
now that bill barr is going after all of
these people
dropping the hammer at justice yeah
they'll be able to form their own antifa
gang in the prison
that's a good point yeah there'll be
enough of them where they're going to be
like you know hanging out together of
course
they'll be the weakest gang because the
super ripped dudes in the other games
are going to be like shut up
yeah i'm going to tell you what to do
let's read a little bit more check this
out
they say one of the protesters is 28
year old modelina mcneil
who according to arrest records was
charged with felonies of criminal
mischief and rioting
oh but but the daily bee said buying
paint you see
how this works it's not rioting to buy
paint you could just buy paint
well apparently if we're taking both at
face value
they're charging with riding for buying
paint no actually
she did buy paint but she later shoved
the police officer
hey let's try this again battery let's
try this again
i'm not scared she faces life in prison
after allegedly shoving a police officer
assaulting a police officer assaulting a
police officer there you go
the july 9 protest was held after gill
said the officer involved shooting that
resulted in the death of bernardo
palacio was justified mcneil who said
she spent tuesday night in jail has
since been released
told kutv that she didn't do anything
wrong but that it would be silly to look
at the potential of life in prison
to look at it would be silly to look at
the potential of life in prison and not
be scared
now to be fair i will say innocent until
proven guilty
all right so we'll you know we'll see
how these things play out there's a
court of law for these things
well i mean she shoved the police
officer that's
that's pretty i haven't seen a video of
it i haven't either yeah cop can tell me
it happened and i'll be like yeah yeah
yeah show me proof
like i don't look i don't like people
who go around starting fights riding
smashing windows and all that stuff
right states still got to prove it
that's true and well i mean if
if it comes down to it the state's going
to believe the police officer oh yeah
yeah
and it's a problem it's a huge problem
but i'll i'll clarify my position
i'm talking about the idea wait wait
hold on are you saying that they should
have more funding for maybe
every cop to have body cams so then they
can be fantastic then live
stream it yeah then they can all be held
accountable for anything that they have
to deal with
here's what i'm saying i don't know
about this lady but i'll tell you two
things
the media is falsely framing the story
first and foremost
i don't know if she actually did it
she's being accused we'll see if you
know the trial proves
beyond a reasonable doubt but the but
we've already got this media outlet
saying she only bought pain
oh no no she she's accused of assaulting
an officer let's be real and smashing
windows and throwing paint around
this story from cbs brings up the issue
of gangnam well they both bring up the
issue of gang enhancement
i am i lean for
gang enhancement charges for these
anti-people 100 i agree
they are they're gangs and i i i looked
actually just now while
while you were talking to find the uh
pictures of the front of the da's office
i can't find it
it's oh really it's lost in my twitter
feed a lot of people oh people were
showing you people were showing me
they're like yo check us out and i was
like whoa
and and now we're talking about enough
now i'm trying to find it i can't even
find it
but i mean the it's covered in red paint
the windows are smashed in it's crazy so
it's
it's it wasn't like they just spilled a
little bit of plain uh
black uh red uh paint everywhere but
it's crazy yeah they poured it over yeah
did you find the picture i found the
picture yeah
oh okay yeah they poured it all over the
place yeah i'll write down the phone i
uh
i did a quick little edit to fix the
article
you did yeah i did i uh i'm just kidding
this is not real i uh while adam was
talking i went i went into the source
code and just changed the the text
after allegedly assaulting an officer oh
wow dude
i fixed it for you daily beasts cool
there's after allegedly assaulting it no
no no i was making a point i was making
a point
but i'm making a point about the media
they could have said she's facing it
and and they could have made the title
something more specific like for
gang enhancement or or for
riding with her gang and assaulting a
da's office and a police officer
what is the job all of those have
happened what is the job of a journalist
well it was to uphold the truth and tell
the people exactly that
to tell to how people understand what's
happening in the world exactly
what did this person just do for the
daily beast confused people
well they they push the narrative they
want people to think
well in in a simple sense they made it
harder to understand what's actually
happening
tucker carlson said this on a show the
other night he said
that here's some stuff that happened and
you know
that's what that's what the news is
supposed to be for
it's for you to decide how you feel
about what has actually happened
and that's what i'm trying news no no i
know right well daily basis is not news
no the daily piece is clearly not new
point i'm making
that's what you just asked me what a
journal what news is supposed to be what
a journalist is supposed to do it's
supposed to
convey the what's actually happening and
and that's
and then you you take what you will from
it a little bit more than that
journalists help you understand the
truth right
what she's doing is the opposite of that
so whatever the opposite of a journalist
is
that's what the daily beast is doing i'm
not going to name the person
but uh you know to put it simply
if someone said to you i i think the
easiest easiest way you can explain it
is the dihydrogen monoxide hoax which
you're familiar with right yeah it's
it's an old school like funny thing
where you say like did you know
dihydrogen monoxide is a you know
corrosive chemical that can eat through
metal
and it's found in cancer cells and
everybody gets all scared and you say we
should ban it and it turns out it's
actually water
and you're framing it in such a way to
confuse them that's not journalism it's
sophistry
so you have these people who are you
have you have some real journalists
but i mean you look at the articles
we've gone through today already with
like the hack of reddit
and you have no real understanding of
what happened with the reddit hack
not journalism to just be like a bunch
of trump messages appeared on the on
this website and people say it was a
hack
it's like well if you want them to
understand the best of their ability
what really happened you need to break
everything down for them and say
but the messages were written in chinese
so we can't necessarily conclude
who or why this was done they don't do
that though
they it's it's like i i i tell you man
these you've got
you've got two kinds of journalists in
the world actually there there's
technically three but let's go
first i would say probably 40
of journalists are sitting in chairs
leaning back with like their
mouth half open drooling going and their
boss comes in and they're like can you
write about this hack thing ugh
i guess and then they look and say trump
hack
they forget to capitalize letters words
are missing
yeah grammar was totally messed up
there's no editor and they hit send and
they publish it they're like there i'm
done can i go home now
then you have i would say about 59
of journalists are just political
operatives trying to figure out ways to
cover a story
as such that it would benefit their
political agenda good point so this is a
much bigger faction
and they're sitting there looking at a
story and they're going dude did you see
this this woman attacking the da's
office this is bad
she's being charged with gang
enhancement now all these people are
just write it and say it was paint
you're right you're right you're right
she brought paint that's it how else can
we frame this to protect them
and then you have one percent of
journalists that are like let's get to
the bottom of this and really understand
this to make sure that our audience has
a firm grasp of the political realities
of our world
and those are the rare ones 100 might
actually be doing it
i mean i'm clapping for you right now no
no no no no no no
don't take this away from me i'm
clapping for you because you're one of
those people
yeah well i think what we do on this is
an attempt to try and break down what's
happening to better understand
what's really going on yeah that's the
gist of everything exactly we i could
sit here and be like wow look at all
those dumb trump supporters who were
hacking reddit and then we were done you
know what i mean
like no like we're actually gonna try
and break it down yeah but this is
unfortunately what you end up getting
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you